Speaker 1: Let's go to Brian from Gainesville,
Georgia, today.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, glad you're doing well.
Thank you.
So it seems like we're on the verge of more
mass hospitalizations from this Delta variant,
so we may be we may or in Georgia, especially
here in Georgia.
So I guess my question is, since vaccinated
people for the most part have largely kind
of returned to mostly return to normal, we're
starting to go into movie theaters now even.
Oh, what I hate to even suggest this, but
should at some point, hospitals consider prioritizing,
for example, when somebody gets into a really
bad car accident and they need instant medical
attention versus somebody who's unvaccinated
and needs medical attention.
I just I just I feel like that because of
the wave of the new coronavirus wave that's
coming through, that the hospitals are just
going to get possibly even more overwhelmed
than when we first went into lockdown.
And I don't
Speaker 1: think it'll get that bad because
there are a lot of people vaccinated who are
very unlikely to get the virus.
And if they do, they're very unlikely to be
symptomatic.
And if they are, they're very unlikely to
be hospitalized.
So I think it's not going to get that bad.
I do think it's going to get bad, particularly
among the unvaccinated population.
But what you're suggesting is complicated
because.
So, like, what's the fundamental of what you're
saying?
Correct me if I'm wrong, is not getting vaccinated
is an irresponsible action.
So therefore, if you need medical attention
as a result of that, you should be lower priority,
more or less.
That's what you're saying, right?
Speaker 4: That's what I'm I don't I don't
know if that's what should be done.
Right.
I'm going to get to what should hospitals
consider that as an option?
I don't especially
Speaker 1: I don't think so.
And the reason why is we know riding a motorcycle
is really dangerous compared to driving in
a car.
Would we say people in motorcycle accidents
should be prioritized from car accidents?
No, no, people wouldn't say that.
We know that smoking is a self-destructive
and and negative to your health activity.
Does that mean if you smoke and you go and
you have, I don't know, a pulmonary embolism?
I don't even know if smoking can cause that,
but some lung thing acute.
You go to the emergency room and they go,
sorry, the kid who broke his ankle gets priority
because the kid doesn't smoke.
The kid was just playing basketball.
It it it just you know, hospitals have a duty
to treat and they have triage protocols.
And I just I know what you're saying, which
is it's such an easy thing.
You just go get vaccinated.
You reduce the chances of clogging up the
medical system.
I just don't think in practice it's going
to it's really something that can be done.
Speaker 4: I see, I see, and I think I think
you're right, I don't I don't think it will
get that bad.
But I'm also looking at this from this perspective
of like, for example, when we went into lockdown.
Yep.
A lot of us stayed home.
We were off the roads.
We didn't you know, that helped with that
help to some extent with with car crashes.
Yeah.
Which like so I'm a traffic engineer, for
example.
So I see I have seen throughout this year
the even though there were fewer cars on the
road, there was an increase in there was an
increase particularly in deaths.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Per capita capita car accident
deaths.
Yeah.
Speaker 4: Yeah, yes indeed.
So I noticed that.
And I think some of that is possibly due to,
you know, OK, there's fewer people on the
road so people feel more comfortable driving
at higher speeds.
And that's when those collisions take place.
Absolutely.
That's the theory.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, it's the same thing, like
if you were driving irresponsibly fast.
So we're going to treat the person with the
headache first.
It just doesn't work that way.
That's not the way our system works.
Speaker 4: Yeah, indeed.
Speaker 1: But a very, very important topic.
And I appreciate you bringing it up.
Speaker 4: Thank you, David.
All right,
Speaker 1: thank you very much.
All right, guys, excellent topics today.
For the most part, that does it for calls
today.
We're going to take a quick break.
We'll be back with more show today.
And we will take your calls again, Fearnot.